live from Palm Springs this is
entertainment tonight first of all
congratulations I was telling Regina we
I sat with my husband and our 27 year
old son and we watched along with
several similar aged kids you know it's
not like these kids had all read much
James Baldwin but they're well educated
they had read some James Baldwin you
brought it to beautiful life berry
Regina it's so wonderful to have you
here and the film is such a masterpiece
thank you very much you know I think for
me I've always been someone who was a
fan of James Baldwin and hoped he would
be more widely read and so I think if
you come away from the film and the
first thing you think is James Baldwin
is brilliant I think that's a win you
know that was the whole point it was
made out of love for Baldwin yeah
interesting that you mentioned your son
and the friends similar age my son would
not have gone to see this film if his
mother was not in it and I saw it for
the first time at TIFF and it's myself
my son and Bryan Tyree enry who was in
the film as well seeing it for the first
time and it moved us in different places
but so I was strongly and I remember
looking at him and looking at Bryan and
emoting at different times and
afterwards we all went backstage and
kind of congregated together and just
gave a love hug because that's what the
film did for us and my son said
it's the first time I've ever seen
myself in a film and to hear your 22
year old say that he's never really felt
like the repeat never felt seen is
something
[Music]
you trust him love his wife
[Music]
so quickly you talked about your first
memory of Palm Springs nine years old
timeshare okay when I first interviewed
Regina about this film she was in a
timeshare in Mexico timeshare thing
rubbed off yeah I mean the thing is it's
so interesting because when I my idea of
Palm Springs always has been what it was
for me as a little girl and a go at me
the races with you riding bikes
barbecuing you know swimming at
nighttime with bats wine
as a good 9 euro that's like amazing let
you go back to school like we were
swimming with bats you know it's such a
special city to me because the nostalgia
is real
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]